i remember hearing that you guys said
the chemistry test between you all was
so intense so i'm wondering like what
made it so intense and and what do you
each remember most about that chemistry
test together and i think what made it
intense was that we were on well i was
auditioning for a batman movie i felt
like i was still auditioning yeah yeah
and i think um you know yeah it's a big
deal and when you get so close to
something that you you want so badly
it's you know it's um
it's scary it's intense it's intense and
you're trying to act like it's not a bit
yeah i'm trying to be like i don't care
[Music]
and inside you're like
please please please please please
please yeah basically that's exactly
what's going on the intensity is really
trying to mask all of the nerves and
excitement forget those latest it's all
about the wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strength
well i love the movie and i feel like
robert especially um the ending of this
movie does leave the door open for like
sequels or other films things that could
happen in the same universe are you
interested in suiting up again yeah for
sure i mean yeah
i know
i was talking to matt about it yesterday
and it's funny because he keeps saying
that he's got id he's like yeah we've
been talking about sequels i'm like who
have you been talking about to sequels i
mean i really want to kind of like can i
be in tell me what the sequel is right
but uh yeah they're the last to know
definitely but yeah there's so much i
mean i love the cast in there i mean i
love working with matt and it's uh
and i just yeah i'm so proud of the
movie and it you know be so fun to do it
again
why are you under there
what are you hiding selena don't throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
zoey what about you i mean how do you
feel about their you know the final
scene with batman and catwoman and what
do you think the future of this
relationship could be and i think it's a
really it's a very romantic scene it's a
very sad scene and i think you know the
hope is that the audience at that point
is invested in our connection i think
it's it's going to be a very complicated
road ahead you know i think we're we're
so we're so similar and we're yet we're
so different and we we need each other
and yet we also want to be i think on
our own so um i think it's so wonderful
to have a setup like this where you know
we're the audience hopefully will be so
invested in in our in our emotional
connection and then we get to see
what happens in the future i felt like i
was watching two quintessential
aquarians and i say that because i am
one that like i'm close oh wait come
close go away
yes that's right
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend to yours
i'm not so sure
can i ask you guys about the costumes in
this film because zoe you know
it looked like it was you put that thing
on with ease i don't know how tough it
was getting it on but it was like
slip slip i'm good
yeah it wasn't like that they had to
make a different suit specifically for
that scene to make it look
easy but uh
normally it would take like two people
helping me get in and out of that thing
so i was gonna i can't just
which is why but yeah
it was true i was like holy sh she got
in that thing like like that she could i
had one
i had to practice that i had to practice
that a lot and with the nails too they
kept on getting caught on things it
started very awkward what about for you
robert how long did it take to get in
and out of the batman suit and was there
is there something you would change
about the suit like looking back
i mean i got pretty good at getting in
and out of it by the end
but definitely i mean
we kind of realized because at first we
would put on each individual element
separately which would took
it took an hour and a half
and then i remember nick the guy who was
helping me get into it every day he's
like hold on a second why are we doing
this we can just have it all attached to
the suit yeah and it's
pretty it was and it was a promotion
it all out putting it in little
individual itemized boxes it was like
this and that was like the first month
of doing i'm like this doesn't make any
sense how we're doing this
um
the only thing uh yeah we we did a lot
of scenes in them
in the rain and uh trying to put on
waterproof or like insulated suit that
like kind of um
whatever it's called i think that latex
type of thing yeah yeah which doesn't
even keep the water out no it holds the
water
holds freezing cold it holds the water
closer to you longer and also the suits
are actually they're really kind of
quite tight as well and so when you try
and put any kind of extra layer
underneath i mean you can't i mean you
literally suddenly feel like the
michelin man and you kind of feel like
you definitely don't feel kind of slinky
no
i love it by the way zoe i mean this is
kind of your year because you're doing
everything acting you're about to direct
you're about to direct your first uh
your first movie and i spoke with
channing a little bit ago and he said
that his one piece of advice to you was
like don't try to do both i just don't
think you enjoy it like i think i didn't
enjoy i didn't get to enjoy really
directing because i don't feel like you
know what you need twice the time if
you're going to be in the movie are you
still rounding out your cast and um you
know are you taking that advice do you
want to star in it too i'm absolutely
not starring in in that film i i don't i
it's hard enough to to act on on your
own i don't know how people do both so i
will not be in the movie i'll just be
directing it one thing at a time i like
it you took that advice there you go
that was good advice then i do have to
ask you about hosting snl how geeked are
you to do this and what are you most
looking forward to
to uh host the show
i'm i mean it's just it's been a dream
of mine for a very long time i'm a huge
fan of the show i'm totally geeked i'm
totally scared
um but i you know i think the cast is so
incredible and i think the thing i'm
looking forward to most is kind of
getting the look behind the curtain and
having the experience of you know seeing
how they come up with the skits and and
all of that so i'm i'm i'm ready and i'm
excited and nervous
rob were you going to be watching
supporting of course oh yeah for sure
that kind of man i just found out it was
yesterday i'm like no way